up to a million protesters are expected
in the streets of Puerto Rico today to
protest the governor who says he is not
stepping down Governor Ricardo Rocio
announced last night he will not seek
reelection but stopped short of
resigning he faces backlash after
details of an obscenity laced online
chat involving him became public CTM
lead national correspondent David beg
know is in the middle of the protests in
San Juan David been following a
reporting all weekend on social media
did the governor's announcement appease
protesters at all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after Governor Ricardo Rosa's
announcements protesters blocked the
only entrance to a government building
in Guaynabo where the governor had met
with mayor's from his party the governor
was able to get out but there were some
lawmakers who were trapped police moved
in after a couple of hours using smoke
bombs and pepper spray to disperse the
crowd around San Juan people were
banging pots and pans in protest back in
front of the governor's mansion
protestors were nearly unanimous in
their reaction to the governor's
decision to stay in office I felt
frankly insulted that he thought that he
could get away with just not running for
governor Don 2020 like what
we're not asking to compromise with you
sir we want you out they are furious
after leaked chats show the governor and
associates using profane homophobic
language attacking critics and making
fun of people who died during hurricane
Maria I was hungry I didn't have water I
didn't have anything and then this guy
was living it off now for all you're not
fit to be governor out it's not even
personal anymore it's more about that
race that we have inside that we have
like really dumb people running this
place and we just won the mountain the
man you just saw in that story is
actually planning to be here today it
has been so interesting to tell the
stories of everyday Puerto Ricans who
want
be here today people who are taking off
of work to be here again the question
becomes what is the governor going to do
what a man who was elected with 640
thousand votes sees upwards of a million
people in the streets all United for his
resignation and to be continued thank
you thank you David Beck now reporting
from San Juan